so if I can have your hands thank you
and you can close your ice session start
with holding hands building up to a bit
of this and just get attuned Rebecca
McCullough is a professional cuddler
it's in no way sexual the boundaries are
made absolutely clear to clients from
the start and while it might seem a bit
unusual there are plenty of reasons why
people are paying to be hugged I am
autistic and for me I find relationships
particularly difficult my sessions with
Rebecca so introduce able to fill that
void for me without any of be sort of
pressures because otherwise I wouldn't
really have that intimate of the human
touch which I think we actually do need
I for a connection to a touch which is a
completely platonic in an ideal world
you can you can have the courage to ask
from your friend for your family member
or a partner whoever but but in this
world where we live definitely I think
is a very safe and healthy space for
someone to to go for their own
self-discovery journey paying to be
cuddled might not be everyone's cup of
tea but with online communication
replacing genuine human interaction
there's mounting evidence that making
fewer meaningful connections has an
adverse impact on our health at
Liverpool John Moores University an
extensive study is underway that's
exploring the importance of the touch
system in humans oxytocin levels
increase endogenous opioid levels
increase serotonin is one of the main
euro transmitters that we know is
impacted by gentle touch tactile
interaction matters a great deal and if
that doesn't happen effectively then
there are consequences to your
well-being
so Pancras train station has seen many a
welcome home embrace over the years my
dad always said you can't beat your
daily hug like a dog does to make you
feel a lot better
everybody's solid handshake that's
that's the best way forward and leave it
at that it might not seem like much but
rather than striving to be self-reliant
for the good of our health
perhaps we could all do with being just
a little more tactile Katie Spencer Sky
News